you're gonna get a lot of that yeah I
guess I don't know we crushed it though
and you guys helped a lot I really want
that to happen for his fun well thanks
man but that but the Theo von show that
I want is the show about him and his
life back home all those characters you
doing your standup mm-hmm
that's the show make that boy Gert yeah
you going home right
and you reuniting with y'all you're all
[ __ ] up friends mm-hmm I'm just
dealing something with just all those
stories there's just heavenly
dude we had his kid in our money run
named Robert and he was like he thought
he was twins that never got separated
right and so yeah when he would talk he
would say something and then under his
breath you would say it again oh it
never ended yeah and if all scared the
[ __ ] out of everybody bro and he could
not stop doing it he kept like an echo
yeah Wow and you'd ask him what I did
and he said he was - there was twins
inside him and one of them never got it
that's so funny like that guy who took
out this massive tumor it was like
freaking 60 pound tumor and when they
inspected it or dissected it they found
like basically it was his twin that had
never really differentiate population
huh yeah did he say something the twin
like a man did like you ever seen like
stone babies what's that well stone baby
czar basically like stillborns like when
women when a woman is pregnant and the
baby dies over time like usually the
woman expels it like it has to come out
but her body sort of make builds this
wall around it so there's this calcified
body in there for like her whole life
wait wait is there photos online of
stone baby oh my god I'm on the Internet
I could see you guys having a couple in
here I'm way honestly shot stone babies
stone day I'm looking it up stone baby I
haven't been here in a long time I like
a year no no there's a stone baby right
here bro the rulings been here
oh I feel like you could eat it so sad
no you can't really cool because they're
actually like hard rock rock hard you
can boil calcified oh look at this stone
baby look I think that's a baby they got
stone that's not a stone baby no baby
what just a baby it was Bobby seemed
like what does Bobby seem like a lot of
time what about this what is this
Harlequin ichthyosis Harlequin Harlequin
ichthyosis yeah you know these these
ones grow up you know that put the
glasses on the-- yeah
no no have you ever seen Holly Carla
Harlequins grow up and you don't want it
I want to show you Harley airy
I know older yeah which is scary
yeah what do you think scares committee
that's what they look like when they get
a little long but when they're born is
like this as closing as I'm what do you
think makes comedians not want to have
children you think I don't know but
because none of our friends have kids I
mean if this came out if Clive had a
baby and this came out and it was don't
put that out in the universe yeah what
is wrong with you Bob declare it I would
just take it gosh what would you do with
it it's dead no this is a lot demonic
one baby I would take it and I would do
now living in with it you're gonna get
bust and I would charge I would charge
money to see what are you talking about
you sound like what do you who are you
Elizabeth Smart get your act you sound
like that guy that tickle is this smart
that crazy got volt or mortal what was
the guy's name
Darrin Voldemort yeah
[Music]